bonjour merci d'être avec nous sur arte
france vous êtes justement en suède un
pays toujours réfractaire au port du
masque pourtant on sait que le coc vide
a déjà fait plus de 5700 à victimes là
bas pourquoi un tel refus la suède n'a
pas changé sa politique depuis le début
de l'épidémie
aujourd'hui les statistiques sont
stables et ses autorités de santé
publique l'ont toujours dit que le match
n'était pas une nécessité
notre épidémiologiste en html explique
qu'il n'ya pas d'études prouvant que le
masque à une réelle valeur pour limiter
une épidémie la stratégie du pays
aujourd'hui elle est également que les
citoyens qui sont par exemple malades ne
se déplace pas avec un masque mais
plutôt restent chez eux
il faut aussi se demander à quoi servent
les masques ils sont essentiels pour les
pros les soignants pour se protéger au
quotidien et aussi pour les patients qui
sont contagieux mais ce n'est pas une
solution miracle de les avoir dans la
rue je ne pense pas je trouve que c'est
compréhensible de demander à la
population à la population de les avoir
en période épidémique dans les lieux
clos mais surtout associé à une
distanciation sociale et au lavage de
mains et je trouve sont plus centraux
plus important vous êtes je rappelle
médecins externe aujourd'hui qu'il est
ajoutée rend la situation dans les
hôpitaux
est-ce que plus globalement le virus
continue de circuler en suède alors oui
effectivement je travaille dans les
services infectieux à lund dans le sud
de la suède
nous avons alors aujourd'hui un patient
hospitalisé à cause du kobe 19 dans tout
l'hôpital
donc c'est une situation qui est très
stable je parlais également à mes
collègues de de stockholm la semaine
dernière qui disent qu'il ya un flux de
patients qui est extrêmement limité
qu'aux vide le virus circule toujours
évidemment l'objectif n'est pas
d'arrêter la propagation total de ce
virus car c'est impossible c'est un
virus qui est très épidémique mais de
contrôler cette propagation qu'on ne pas
être surchargés et la situation est sous
contrôle et il n'y a pas de nouveau
cluster observé pour le moment hormis
ces gestes barrières pour tenter de
continuer à lutter contre l'épidémie de
kovy 19 dans le pays que préconise
actuellement le gouvernement à sa
population
comme je vous dis la stratégie a pas
forcément évolué depuis
depuis ces derniers mois la situation
ici à évoluer dans le bon sens comme la
plupart des pays d'europe d'ailleurs
donc la suède n'a pas changé sa
politique c'est toujours les gestes
barrière la distanciation sociale et
l'adaptation des structures des lieux
publics et transports en commun et c'est
évidemment l'interdiction des
rassemblements de plus de 50 personnes
et de déconseiller aux personnes à
risques est âgé de sortir de chez eux
mais à part ça il n'y a pas de piles n'y
a pas plus de mesures prises en compte
on a beaucoup entendu parler de cette
présumée immunité collective prônée par
les autorités suédoises une approche qui
a suscité de nombreuses critiques
justement plusieurs mois après le début
de la crise que pensez vous de cette
stratégie et quel bilan en tirez jusqu'à
maintenant je pense que l'immunité
collective est un objectif que tous les
pays du monde aimerait atteindre et je
pense d'abord que la suède a basé sa
stratégie sur le contrôle du flux de
patients vers les hôpitaux pour ne
jamais atteindre la surcharge qui a été
atteinte dans certains autres pays qui
ont malheureusement été touché plus tôt
et plus durement par l'épidémie tout en
essayant de préserver aussi un
fonctionnement relativement normale du
pays quel bilan en tirez les groupes de
la suède sont loin d'être parfaite ça je
ne peux pas vous le dire on a un nombre
plus important de morts par capita que
la france par exemple
mais si on veut parler de la situation
actuelle on a aujourd'hui une situation
qui est très stable il n'ya plus
surmortalité par rapport aux années
précédentes à la même période
et nous ne sommes plus dans la phase
épidémique aigu du virus mais plutôt
dans une phase l'attend avec un taux
d'infection très bas et quasi pas de
places d'hospitalisation
merci beaucoup aux diverses formes
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous avez un médecin
externe à l'hôpital de lund en suède au
revoir